Rock.
Paper.
Scissors.
A simple hand game dating back to the Han
Dynasty of Imperial China.
It is a decisive game between two players,
with the only outcomes being win, lose, or
draw.
We’re quite familiar with the Rock-Paper-Scissors
here at the SCP Foundation,
as the guards are often seen playing intense
rounds of the game to determine
who will be the unlucky soul chosen to secure
one of various keter-class SCPs during a given
week.
In most cases, this use of Rock-Paper-Scissors
is accepted as a largely harmless and fair
way for defensive personnel to arrange their
shifts.
The reason for this is that the results of
Rock-Paper-Scissors are generally random,
as there are very few ways for an individual’s
skill to influence the game.
Or so one might think.
In reality, Rock-Paper-Scissors is a deeply
psychological game,
and this is mainly because of its origin as
a contest between fellow human beings.
The average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns,
and with only three options to keep track
of,
it is entirely possible for a seasoned veteran
of rock-paper-scissors to predict their opponent’s
choice before any hands are thrown.
Of course, that opponent may also commit an
error of their own, by misreading the other
player’s actions,
and thus there is always a chance for an impulsive
decision to swing the results of the game
in either direction.
Human limitation is the only skill-based mechanic
in the game of Rock-Paper-Scissors,
and that same limitation is what - in the
eyes of some - holds the game back from reaching
its true potential.
That was the case, until someone out there
discovered the rules to an anomalous version
of Rock-Paper-Scissors being spread through
a mysterious email.
While all attempts to trace the email back
to its original sender have left the Foundation
with more questions than answers,
we have been able to learn more about the
differences between the rules of standard
Rock-Paper-Scissors and the anomalous version.
We have given this anomalous version of Rock-Paper-Scissors
the designation SCP-4633, and unlike the classic
edition
- under no circumstances are any Foundation
personnel allowed to play a game incorporating
any of the alternative rules.
While the ceiling for skill and variety is
theoretically much higher in a Rock-Paper-Scissors
match featuring SCP-4633,
the risks to the players far outweigh any
added novelty.
Here is how SCP-4633 functions during an average
game of Rock-Paper-Scissors…
well, average prior to the anomalous properties
taking effect:
rather than being limited to using merely
rock, paper, or scissors - as the name of
the game implies
- the players gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures
which upon the act of being thrown become
seamlessly integrated into both players’
shared understanding of the rules.
This alone would be bizarre enough, but the
true harm caused by SCP-4633 is in the nature
of the gestures themselves.
When one of the non-standard gestures allowed
by SCP-4633 is used,
the players’ hands will change shape in
ways that, under normal circumstances, would
be anatomically impossible.
Each of these non-standard gestures is distinct
from the next,
with the only commonality being an unusual
tendency for the final gesture to resemble
biological structures often seen in sea life.
One particular gesture might cause a player
to rapidly grow a ring of additional fingers
surrounding a gaping anemone-like mouth in
the palm,
while another could result in the player’s
entire arm flattening into a fin-like appendage.
Regardless of how severe a departure from
a typical human limb the final gesture would
be,
the limbs – and on rare occasions, the entire
body – of the player using the gesture will
quickly and irreversibly mutate into the shape
required to successfully perform it.
While these gestures overwhelmingly result
in forms that would be distressing to most
people,
the same cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the rules
also appears to apply to the changes affecting
their own bodies.
To the players of an SCP-4633-augmented match
of Rock-Paper-Scissors, the nonstandard gestures
seem as mundane as the original three.
Unfortunately, the morphic properties of SCP-4633
are practically irreversible,
with extreme reconstructive surgery being
required in even the best of cases.
In all instances of SCP-4633, surgical intervention
is necessary to prevent the spread of details
regarding the non-standard gestures and their
usage.
Because of the immediate shift in cognitive
awareness among participants, all that is
needed for a new instance of SCP-4633 to occur
is the faintest hint of knowledge of the alternative
rules.
It’s even been noted that between different
groups of players,
the non-standard gestures can vary heavily
or seemingly be created on the fly as the
desire to win at all costs takes hold.
Here are a few examples of anomalous gestures
which have been observed during instances
SCP-4633.
The list is by no means comprehensive,
but it will provide an insight into how SCP-4633
drastically alters the existing mechanics
of the game
as well as the physique of the players.
The “Thu-ry-leh” gesture transforms the
user’s fingers into barbed tentacles.
It beats paper and scissors, but loses to
rock.
“Cha-voo-aga” folds the fingers of the
hand into the palm and causes them to emerge
through the back of the palm.
It allows the user to throw a second gesture
after they’ve seen their opponent’s choice.
“Aj-kel-haz” splits the hand into a pair
of poisonous stingers which also produce a
potent electrical current between them.
It has been seen to lose to paper, but seemingly
of their own will,
the stingers lashed at the opposing player
and caused them to fall unconscious three
rounds later due to the effects of the poison.
“Sha-ooh-sa” beats paper and two other
anomalous gestures; loses to scissors, rock
and a third gesture
and morphs the user’s arm into a dactyl
club similar to the front appendages of a
mantis shrimp.
“Iz-urg-av” simply causes the player to
grow three additional thumbs on one hand.
The final gesture resembles a triple thumbs
up.
Iz-urg-av has not been seen to beat any gestures,
and the player who uses it always seems to
go on to lose the match.
“Pag-ak-mar” causes the middle and ringer
to recede into the hand,
while the pointer and pinky fingers extend
to resemble the eye stocks of a snail or slug.
The rest of the hand also becomes coated in
a thin layer of slime which continues to secrete
from within.
Pag-ak-mar beats scissors and paper, but loses
to rock and another anomalous gesture known
as “vah-yan-jek.”
Incidentally, vah-yan-jek causes the arm of
the player using it to elongate into a worm-like
tube that periodically spews a gout of salt
water on the opponent.
When vah-yan-jek was seen beating pag-ak-mar,
the salt water appeared to have some adverse
effect on the latter gesture,
causing the eyestalks to droop and the hand
to shrivel until it was half its original
size.
Another anomalous gesture is “gra-zath-rog”
recognized by the skin, muscle, and veins
of the hand turning translucent,
revealing a pulsing red organ in the interior
of the palm.
Once gra-zath-rag has been thrown, the player
who used it may call out the name of one other
gesture,
which can no longer be used in the current
match.
The “uka-yag” gesture is a bit deceptive,
as it resembles rock when first thrown, but
gradually causes the hand to condense into
a lump of inert material
not dissimilar to actual igneous rock.
The knuckles as well begin to exude a superheated
mineral substance similar to molten lava.
Uka-yag exclusively beats paper and appears
to lose to everything else.
Many of the gestures on record have no known
name,
but their function within SCP-4633’s altered
rules is clear from the context in which they
were used.
Such is the case with one anomalous gesture,
which caused most of the player’s hand to
withdraw into a siphon-like opening at their
wrist
before the very same orifice shot a stream
of ink into the opposing player’s eyes.
While there was no lasting harm done to the
opponent by this gesture,
the ink did cause temporary blindness,
which persisted until they were defeated by
way of their rock losing to paper.
Another unknown gesture has been seen beating
both iz-urg-av and uka-yag.
This gesture makes the player’s hand resemble
the crest and gas-filled body of a pacific
man-o-war.
These examples are only scraping the surface
of the seemingly endless possibilities that
SCP-4633 has to offer.
As you can see, the anomalous hand gestures
can be just as dangerous within the game itself
as the permanent changes they invoke in the
user.
While the Foundation has done its best to
contain all information surrounding SCP-4633,
there have been clear efforts by several unknown
groups to push the game into continued usage.
Over the past three decades, instances of
SCP-4633 have seen increasing popularity in
the world of high-stakes gambling.
Perhaps it is because of the inherent thrill
of watching two opponents trying to strategically
outwit each other
with a countless number of non-standard gestures,
but more likely, it is part of the anomalous
effects of SCP-4633 that the game would appeal
to those desperate to risk everything
on a slim chance of victory.
This neatly brings us to the SCP-4633-related
incident which occurred aboard the private
ocean liner known as the SS Fateful Emma.
Before the incident, the Fateful Emma would
sail into international waters twice a year.
Each time it would bring along a new group
of passengers,
seemingly selected from the underprivileged
and downcast sector of society.
A great many of these passengers were convicts
with repeat violent offenses chosen from supermax
facilities the world over.
The process by which these inmates were chosen
for a voyage aboard the ship was not dissimilar
from the methods the Foundation uses to acquire
new Class-D Personnel.
Naturally, this was how the research team
was able to be tipped off about the Fateful
Emma.
It became apparent soon after looking into
the ship’s career that individuals altered
by the effects of SCP-4633 had been seen departing
from the ship on multiple occasions in remote
island harbors.
Most of the time, the individuals would also
be - to the best of their ability with their
metamorphosed forms
- carrying briefcases filled with hundreds
of thousands of dollars in cash.
While witnesses tended to write off the strange
appearances of those affected as being the
result of deformity or injury
– or in more pronounced instances dismissing
the encounters as sightings of creatures from
the local mythology
– it was clear to anyone familiar with SCP-4633
what was truly going on.
These passengers were being made to play pitched
games of Rock-Paper-Scissors featuring SCP-4633
for massive sums of wealth, and what was worse:
the grand prize winners were seemingly being
released back into civilization without the
knowledge of law enforcement.
Of course, what the Foundation was most concerned
about was the potential for a large-scale
leak of detailed information involving SCP-4633.
It seemed that the Foundation’s latest faceless
enemy had revealed itself.
Whatever wealthy group of individuals was
pulling the strings behind the games aboard
the SS Fateful Emma,
it was very likely that the ship was also
well-protected by a private army of trained
mercenaries.
In a display of swift but necessary initiative,
The Foundation assembled a brand new Mobile
Task Force to be dispatched onto the ocean
liner:
Mobile Task Rho-52 with the fitting codename
“Rochambeau.”
The mobile task force would board the vessel
secretly,
and use whatever means necessary to prevent
the spread of SCP-4633
and any evidence of the associated non-standard
hand gestures.
Before the Fateful Emma’s next voyage, the
Foundation isolated the port where it would
depart from and made sure that the MTF agents
were in position.
The operation was co-captained by Agent Dubois
and Agent Zheng,
both of whom prided themselves on having extraordinary
good luck.
Agent Dubois would stealthily move the majority
of the agents under his command into the cargo
hold below deck,
and await Agent Zheng’ signal.
Agent Zheng himself would assume the name
and identity of one of the criminal passengers,
who was intercepted before boarding by the
mobile task force.
The would-be participant was subsequently
detained and brought into the Foundation as
a Class-D personnel.
As the SS Fateful Emma began to leave the
harbor,
Agent Zheng joined the other passengers who
had been gathered together in an enormous
function hall.
There was little indication of when the games
would begin, and Zheng made an effort to keep
a low profile until more information was available.
Shortly after the ship had officially arrived
in international waters,
an eccentric man entered the room on a walkway
that overlooked the rest of the passengers.
He was flanked by a pair of armed bodyguards.
It was plain from the man’s style of dress
and demeanor that he was both absurdly wealthy
and completely out of his mind.
He wore a pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of a
Siberian tiger.
A pair of dark shades with sequined rims obscured
his eyes from view,
but by far the strangest aspect of the rich
man’s was the fact that emerging from the
wrist of his right arm
was the eyeless head of a moray eel where
his hand should be.
The man spoke, addressing the entire room:
“Welcome, passengers new and old, to the
SS Fateful Emma!
While you are aboard this ship, your fate
is in your own hands.
Over the next twenty-four hours, you will
have the rare opportunity to play the greatest
game of chance that humanity has ever known!
Generations of people from every continent
and every walk of life have given their all
to the mastery of rock-paper-scissors-ack-rah-nos-vaf-lyl-tog-char-sth...”
The man proceeded to speak unusual syllables
for the next minute straight without even
a pause for breath.
In his report, Agent Zheng described the man’s
voice as gaining an increasingly loud hum
as his speech continued and that some of the
syllables didn’t seem to be the product
of human vocal cords.
He soon concluded his string of gibberish
and resumed speaking intelligible language:
“As is customary, we will be utilizing the
ill-gesh-toe-eee rules.
You will begin by selecting a single opponent
and challenging them to a best two of three
match.
This is a single elimination tournament, and
any competitors who cannot otherwise continue
to engage in matches will also be eliminated.
By the end of your time here, the luckiest
among you will be named the undisputed champion
of these games and will be granted unlimited
freedom along with the cash prize!
The rest of you will have to determine your
own fates, for you all know what awaits you
below.
May your hands be ready, your minds be sharp,
and remember… winning is everything!”
With a flourish of his moray eel hand, the
wealthy man finished his introductions and
promptly exited the room.
Agent Zheng looked at the passengers surrounding
him and saw that they were already beginning
to play rock-paper-scissors with each other.
A few had already begun using the anomalous
gestures, warping their limbs into hideous
sub-nautical shapes.
Agent Zheng gave the signal to Agent Dubois
and the rest of the mobile task force to begin
the operation.
Their target was primarily the moray-handed
man,
as well as any other close associates that
he had on board.
They would capture him alive and interrogate
him into revealing the mystery behind this
illegal gambling ring.
Once the mercenaries were dealt with, Agent
Dubois’ team would commandeer the ocean
liner and navigate it to SCP Foundation Research
Site 45 to await further orders.
As for Agent Zheng, he knew what he had to
do.
To buy time, he would participate in the ensuing
rock-paper-scissors tournament and eliminate
as many of the other players as possible.
This, he believed, was the best way to minimize
the number of anomalous gestures that would
be used aboard the ship.
Of course, he himself wouldn’t be using
any of the anomalous gestures either - opting
to limit himself to the standard three.
This could put him at a severe disadvantage
over the course of the competition, but Agent
Zheng knew better than to tempt fate.
Still, being eliminated seemed like something
he may want to avoid.
Even though the consequences for elimination
were left vague in the strange rich man’s
speech,
he still didn’t feel that it would be wise
to put himself in a compromised position while
aboard the Fateful Emma.
Bracing himself for the worst, Agent Zheng
accepted the challenge of a nearby passenger.
He was off to a promising start when he threw
a scissors hand against his opponent’s paper.
Because the matches were best two out of three,
all he needed was to win one of the next two
matches, and he’d have survived this round.
Then he saw the devious look on his opponent’s
face, and he knew that this match was about
to get weird.
Rather than admit defeat, Agent Zheng prepared
to throw scissors again.
The two challenged their hands, and just as
Zheng had feared, his opponent threw an anomalous
gesture.
Almost instantly, the opponent’s hand took
on a multi-mouthed piscine form
which began to spit sharp teeth in Agent Zheng’s
direction.
Fortunately, the agent’s bulletproof vest
was able to withstand the impact of the teeth.
What was even more fortunate was the fact
that the opponent seemed to be a good sport.
“Scissors beats Az-rah-vok.
You win,” said the other passenger before
walking away in search of their next match.
Curiously, the passenger’s transformed arm
continued to fire teeth across the room at
random intervals,
occasionally hitting and causing injury to
one of the other competitors.
Agent Zheng was grateful that the body armor
he was wearing had been tested to withstand
rapid fire from SCP-127.
Compared to the raw power of the living gun,
the teeth launched from the “Az-rah-vok”
gesture were practically BB rounds.
He had succeeded in not being eliminated,
both from the game and generally.
Excited about his win, Zheng sought out another
opponent to test his luck.
Below deck, Agent Dubois and the rest of the
mobile task force had just finished facing
off against some of the hired mercenaries
when they entered a room presumed to be the
liner’s sick bay.
Inside was a grisly sight: a second rock-paper-scissors
tournament playing out between players
that had been so thoroughly transformed by
the anomalous gestures of SCP-4633
that they barely appeared to still be human.
It was like a scene from a deep sea documentary,
with strange and unknowable creatures vying
for dominance
- not within a natural food chain or competition
for resources but within a seemingly never-ending
struggle to win a game of chance.
It was purgatory.
Rock-paper-scissors-purgatory.
Agent Dubois was appalled, but he knew better
than to attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all distracted.
The moray-handed man was still somewhere in
the ship, and capturing him was far more important.
The research team would decide what to do
with these former humans once the entire ship
was secure within the Foundation’s custody.
However, what Agent Dubois didn’t realize
is that some of these creatures were advancing
on his team.
In nightmarish and unearthly voices, they
chanted:
“Rock… rock… paper…
scissors…”
Suddenly, one of the abominations - who resembled
nothing more closely than an enormous mass
of coral
- produced four arms from within its body
and began to throw anomalous hand signs toward
the agents.
One of the arms threw “uka-yag”, which
coated an unsuspecting agent in hot lava,
causing him to drop to the floor in pain.
Panicked, Dubois ordered the task force to
eliminate every living thing in the sick bay
- although not in the sense of their tournament
standing, of course.
Meanwhile, Agent Zheng was on a win streak
in the function hall.
Through sheer luck and determination had managed
to avoid elimination while eliminating several
other passengers himself.
He began to notice that those who were eliminated
were quietly escorted away by the bouncers,
seemingly to have their anomalous changes
treated.
Now it was down to only twelve remaining passengers.
Agent Zheng knew that it was only a matter
of time before Dubois and his team took control
of the ship
but feeling reckless, he challenged one of
the remaining passengers.
In that moment, something came over him, as
if his determination to see the mission through
was also compelling him to win at any cost.
His opponent threw pag-ak-mar,
and out of instinct Zheng threw vah-yan-jek.
The agent went on to win the entire tournament,
but sadly, he was unable to collect the prize
money,
as during the skirmish below deck, the man
with the moray hand had escaped with the small
fortune in a high-speed submersible.
His ultimate goals and the scope of the shadowy
group he represented would remain unanswered
for the time being.
When the SS Fateful Emma finally arrived at
Site 45,
Agent Zheng came to his senses and realized
that he had underestimated the cognitive side-effects
of SCP-4633.
Due to the immediately recognizable anomalous
state of both of his arms, Agent Zheng was
later contained on a site with minimal security.
It is believed that researchers are still
searching for a method to reverse the effects.
It just goes to show that winning isn’t
everything.
Now go check out “SCP-439 - Bone Hive”
and “SCP-3989 - The Bone Orchard” for
more terrifying tales of body horror!